um hard to explain you just feel bad
drunk
turned you into some next zombie you're
not yourself no more like
this is xanax also known as zan it's an
anti-anxiety drug which can only be
obtained on private prescription
but across the country it is being
abused by teenagers
what have you got there right so i've
got around tanzania
and this is kind of this is kind of what
most people in bristol would like to
take right now
even though the nhs does not provide
xanax jake and simon
which are not their real names have been
hooked on a drug for the last two years
if we do coke twice twice a week let's
say
we do like three fruits so that adds up
to six
well i wouldn't do it daily like
so you're mixing zen acts of cocaine
yeah afterwards after all
you know off to risk that you're putting
yourself up by doing that you're mixing
one drug with another drug
yeah yeah yeah obviously yeah what do
you think could happen should it go
wrong
well i probably just died maybe many
users have already paid with their lives
across the uk
hundreds of deaths have been linked to
the tranquilizer and according to jake
and simon
their dealer charges less than a pound
for a single pill
we're getting them online for about 30
40 apart
finding the thousands though that's what
makes it so cheap yeah
where are you getting them now we we now
manage to find a plug
and he presses it himself yeah just
local local guys i mean
so when you say a plug that's a dealer
yeah probably means dealer right
this emerging crisis is not just
confined here to bristol
it is becoming a matter of public health
with
experts worried we're only just starting
to see what it is capable of
over the last couple of years there's
been a 300 percent
increase in the number of young people
presenting to services
uh needing support for a range of
benzodiazepine
drugs including xanax here's just how
easy it is for young people to get their
hand on the drug
we've made contact with the dealer
online and he's offering
60 xanax pills for 60 pounds the impact
on users misusing this drug
is not just limited to them mothers like
katie whose 18 year old son
is now in recovery say her life has been
torn apart
the most scary thing i think is the mood
changing it turned my son into a monster
abusive aggressive um yeah shouting
screaming
and really insulting abusive behavior
that he would never do if he wasn't
under the influence of this drug
i know of kids as young as you know 11
12
he'll take one just to just to chill
them out just to relax
with a rising number of young people
misusing xanax
tackling the issue is becoming ever more
urgent
noel phillips sky news bristol